cientos de personas marchan en las
calles de Madrid en defensa de la
sanidad pública un reclamo que llevan
haciendo Los profesionales de este país
durante más de 10 años renuncian el
empeoramiento de sus condiciones y de la
falta de presupuesto en el sector
estamos viviendo un verdadero infierno
con agendas diarias de pacientes
interminables debido al deterioro
progresivo que está sufriendo nuestra
querida atención primaria que se haga el
esfuerzo mayor posible para que haya la
plantilla suficiente que requieren los
centros de salud y los servicios de
urgencias de atención primaria en Madrid
es una especie de laboratorio de ensayo
para
[Música]
digamos
promocionar la sanidad privada para
hacer negocio los largos tiempos de
espera para conseguir una cita con un
médico de familia de atención primaria
que van desde los cinco días hasta los
10 días hacen que muchas personas se
vayan a los hospitales que han recibido
un 40% más de visitas una situación que
califican de insostenible si estáis uno
malo tiene que ser atendiendo ya sin
tener que ir a urgencias
porque llegas a esperar 8 horas y una
sala de urgencia mientras que la OMS que
se invierta un 25% del presupuesto en
sanidad en atención primaria en España
ese porcentaje no llega ni al 14 de
media algo que en Madrid última región
por tres años consecutivos no llega al
11%. esto teniendo en cuenta además que
Madrid es la región de España con el
mayor producto interno bruto del país